those little boys and girls are counting
on us
all of this is for the children for the
children
for the children
[Laughter]
the devil's in the details bev that's
not the only place he is
as you all know
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my one division mephisto video there
have been a lot of mephisto easter eggs
the devil is in the details and that's
not the only place that he is
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'm doing videos for all the wand
division episodes and we're doing a
disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
mephisto
reference or devil reference on the
video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen any of the episodes yet we'll
be talking about everything that's
happened so far and some really old
easter eggs from back in marvel phase
one referencing mephisto there have been
many mephisto easter eggs on one
division so far in the mcu in general
even in some of the other marvel phase 4
series like falcon and winter soldier
and the loki trailer the reason why
mephisto is getting so much attention
right now on one division is because
he's such a big
part of her backstory with the twin
children billy and tommy wicked and
speed
and they're doing that story on the show
mephisto is also a big marvel villain
that both scarlet witch and doctor
strange share in common and one division
will cross over with doctor strange 2
multiverse
of madness in addition to spider-man 3
and a bunch of other stuff so everyone's
just wondering if mephisto
the actual character will show up during
one division
so we'll start with the one division
mephisto easter eggs then i'll talk
about the older ones and some of the
ones in the other marvel
phase 4 trailer videos like falcon
winter soldier and loki
because for instance the older marvel
phase 1 references were for a mephisto
storyline that kevin feige swerved on
and wound up changing their plans for
mephisto and the mcu just in general
changed a long time ago but they're
still really cool easter eggs
the first big one on one division is
actually the iron man stark industries
toastmaster 2000 commercial
if you re-watch the commercial and you
flip the frame upside down
you notice on the first toaster the
regular one
the symbol is actually the numbers 666
the mark of the beast the mark of the
devil then during one division episode 2
that's where they really crank up the
references agatha harkness keeps
referring to her mystery husband
ralph like he's a terrible person and
she can't stand him
the name ralph also translates to famous
wolf in norse mythology similar to the
language the asgardians
thor normally speaks ralph is also the
name of one of the villain characters
during lord of the flies his character
represents
evil during lord of the flies a group of
children get marooned on a remote island
and have to survive
cut off from the regular world during
one division everyone inside the
alternate reality the tv based reality
are cut off from the normal mcu universe
and they keep
talking about children chanting in
unison about children
when you notice that there are no
children anywhere in the town
until scarlet witch gets pregnant at the
end of the episode
those little boys and girls are counting
on us
all of this is for the children for the
children
for the children i want to thank you all
for coming out
to support west view elementary
for the children
totally not creepy when they all chant
in unison multiple times during the
episode like that
but she also tells scarlet witch to
bring ralph
out of the magic box the one with the
graphic of the infinity stone on it
that's meant to be a representation of
vision's origin story in the box that
ultron created him in
as if agatha harkness is implying that
the reason why we haven't seen ralph yet
she only just mentions him and he's off
screen somewhere is because
he can't enter this alternate dimension
yet and agatha harkness is trying to
manipulate scarlet witch into helping
ralph
mephisto nightmare whoever he might wind
up being enter
the main mcu reality and they're using
this alternate reality scenario to do
that
also the bunny that agatha harkness
brings with her during the beginning of
the episode and then you later see
pop-up during the magic show she gives
it to scarlet witch
she says his name is senor scratchy
nicholas scratch is the name of mephisto
the devil
uses during the short story the devil
and daniel webster
which bears some similarities to what's
happening during the one division series
you may remember the simpsons did a
parody of this a long time ago during
treehouse of horror it was the homer
simpson
soul donut episode it plays out like the
original devil vs daniel webster
storyline
during that storyline the devil comes to
a person named mr stone and gives him
seven years of prosperity in exchange
for his soul and when he comes back to
collect
stone bargains for an extra three years
extension after the three years the
devil comes back to collect finally and
refuses to get more extensions
but daniel webster comes along and
offers to help mr stone get out of the
contract
by fighting the devil in court through a
lot of speechifying and legal magic work
daniel webster winds up beating the
devil in court
using a little bit of trickery on one
division this could just be a metaphor
for the way scarlet witch was able to
create this alternate reality to give
her
this time of prosperity with vision
bring him back to life exactly the way
she remembers him have the family she
always wanted
making a deal with the devil so to speak
to make this happen
and then later maybe she tries to get
out of the deal and keep vision in her
twin children but i'm only expecting
some surface level references
and similarities it's not meant to be an
exact copy of that storyline
but the fact that agatha harkness
herself keeps making direct references
to the devil
the devil is in the details and that's
not the only place he is also implies
that she's
somehow connected to that entity and
also when dottie said that the devil is
in the details
you may not remember if you didn't watch
the show but this actress also played a
demon
on buffy the vampire slayer just another
connection to mephisto the devil
but also another call back to the bunny
she was afraid of
bunnies on that tv show so i think
that's just meant to be a really meta
reference to all these different things
including mephisto
the other big marvel phase four mephisto
easter eggs in the loki trailer are in
the stained glass window there's this
depiction of the devil
in this church that is made to look just
like comic book mephisto
page to screen
[Music]
it could just be more evidence that he
exists in the mcu
because it seems like the time variance
authority this organization that loki is
working with here just has a broader
understanding of reality in general in
the multiverse
and i think a lot of us were also
expecting to see teasers for the main
villain of doctor strange 2
during one division and who better than
someone like mephisto or nightmare
nightmare was the previously rumored
villain of doctor strange 2 when scott
derrickson was still directing the movie
now that sam raimi is directing it they
could have changed that just a little
bit
nightmare's powers are just a little bit
different from mephisto but you could
also explain how
nightmare could be the person they're
referring to when they keep talking
about ralph and the devil
but there's also another easter egg
during the falcon and winter soldier
episodes
it doesn't show up in the trailer
footage it actually shows up in footage
of them filming for
scenes that are going to take place in
madrid which is a big x-men location
and obviously scarlet witch big
connection to the x-men characters
you have this biker gang here that
eventually falcon and winter soldier are
going to fight with
the symbol on the backs of all their
jackets is the face
of the devil just another reference to
mephisto even though falcon and winter
soldier is going to be more straight up
action
mcu series like a more traditional big
marvel comic book event like you would
expect
most of the stuff they're going for on
that series is the weapons plus
the super soldier program that kind of
leads to weapon x
so it's also tied to future x-men stuff
wolverine
weapon x so even though falcon and
winter soldier themselves
aren't that related to x-men characters
don't cross over with them that much
during the comics they are still using
that series to set up
big future marvel phase 4 stuff just
like one division
is helping set up mutants in x-men
inside the mcu i'll talk more about that
stuff when we get those falcon and
winter soldier episodes later this year
in march
but the really cool older marvel phase
one mephisto easter egg that goes back
to the first avengers movie is actually
during this scene where nick fury is
coming to recruit captain america for
the avengers team when he's pounding the
bag remember we saw that during the
post-credits scene from the first
captain america movie
you here with a mission sir i am trying
to get me back in the world
trying to save it
hydra's secret weapon he shows up and
gives him a file on the infinity stones
in the tesseract and the file also
mentions mephisto
directly by name so the text if you
can't read it here says
as shield wished to harness the power of
the tesseract
mephisto was enlisted to aid them in
their efforts
studying the cube mephisto proposed that
the tesseract could be as powerful as
the infinity stones
so this is a huge revelation originally
they had intended for mephisto to
actually be working with shield on the
dl
them literally making a deal with the
devil to learn more about the infinity
stones
so it sounds like kevin feige had
mephisto just being a huge part of the
infinity
saga and the infinity gauntlet storyline
because he is a big character during the
comic book version of the infinity
gauntlet storyline but as you saw play
out during marvel phase 2 eventually
marvel phase 3 over time either because
of the china
devil issue or some other reasons they
pivoted away from the mephisto character
and changed the storyline
and now if you re-watch the first
avengers movie in this scene on disney
plus for example
they've digitally removed mephisto's
name from this dossier
so they've kind of retconned this out
but now it just seems like they brought
him back in during marvel phase four in
some way
at least in some form there will
continue to be more
devil in mephisto references during
future one division episodes as part of
her
storyline with her children so i'll just
point them out as we see them i'll
probably have to do another big mephisto
easter egg video after episode 9 just
because there's going to be so much
stuff happening
my full one division episode 3 video is
going to post friday just like normal so
make sure you have alerts turned on for
my channel so you don't miss that and if
you didn't see it paul bettany dropped
this huge bomb recently he just
said that there was an avengers endgame
post credit scene that they wound up
having to delete
that completely set up what was
happening on the one division series
you can click here to watch that post
credit scene and you can click here for
all my other one division episode 1 and
episode 2 videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you